okay not do this me boy is like kind of
scared I hate horror movies I get like
scared really easily I do get scared for
them but I love that feeling the garage
ring when a stranger calls or I know
what you just lost something sinister
it's really because in the conjuring
that's so not fun like why would you put
yourself through like being terrified to
like an hour and a half I really have to
go bathroom so I hope you like something
really scary because I might [ __ ] in no
no no no child no nice cute okay I was
not expecting that since no British echo
egg is not helping the serenity of saw
do not go with them Danny god I'm sorry
oh my god what a power to have to see
that where are his parents I don't know
if that actually that I know yet cuz now
they're gone they just go to in the room
he's definitely talking to his finger
it's making direct eye contact hey
Johnny dad I'm good oh the crop top boy
should wear crop tops more often oh hi
oh oh my where's he going oh so many
things just had a guy god I was not
expecting that up a lot of mom okay go
human body does not have that much blood
in it I feel like something's gonna pop
up this Jane Eyre it's way too quiet
love she's too happy it's not normal
she's like over excessively so big
herself okay good how does she not see
that oh my goodness looks like a shark
bit her how is she not dead yet oh oh my
god this is why I don't shower home
alone she has to be dead what a time to
be alive
that's the creepiest doll I've ever seen
haha this is a great start
why hey we do know don't touch it don't
know stop it you're a training big hair
the expression on the doll was like
really scared is she putting the doing a
liar this woman needs some help
ah looks like he's trying to give her a
hickey your average Friday night for a
small doll that is some words why did
she want it to wake up if it's gonna do
that to her she can just leave her house
this woman is gonna die so many things
just happened I'm pretty sure I was
screaming the whole time yeah it's time
period I'd say it looks pretty good but
for now it seemed a little dated you
wouldn't really see much of what just
happened in a horror movie today a lot
of the ones nowadays are all kind of the
same and very expected these were really
unexpected yeah what are any horror
movie in a dark basement alone which
scare you like I don't think there's any
way not to be scared for that